[Music]
how do you been interviewed by the
special counsel I have you have it and
what sort of questions were they asking
yes text and I can go and discussing
that as well don't know about those
emails before they came out absolutely
he knew about them yes you knew what was
coming out before WikiLeaks released
them you're saying Donald Trump had a
back-channel
I didn't say that you did but I will say
that suppose the corruption that went on
in the campaign and in the White House
I'm gonna continue to blow the whistle
on all of this Omarosa making the rounds
pitching a new book and getting a lot of
attention for what she's saying the
president taking note as well as we
noted when you give a crazed crying
lowlife a break he tweeted this morning
and give her a job at the White House I
guess it just didn't work out good work
by general Kelly for quickly firing that
dog well that tweet got a lot of
attention all over the place how does
Sara Huckabee Sanders take to the White
House podium and defend this man
how does Kellyanne Conway stay silent
today and not go out and at least break
with the president and his calling a
woman a dog how did the senior women in
the cabinet how did the women that get a
paycheck from the American taxpayers
stay silent on a day like today people
trying to get away with saying that
Donald Trump is terrible to women who
work for him and that he's a sexist
misogynist why would I be standing here
in front of the White House working this
building if I didn't think this man was
doing great for all Americans and by the
way if I felt that he wasn't respectful
toward women he's an excellent boss to
women it's when Thomas says she wouldn't
have obviously used those particular
words let's bring in our panel
Steve Hilton is a former adviser to
British Prime Minister David Cameron and
hosted the next revolution here on fox
news channel Karen Tumulty opinion
writer for The Washington Post and guy
Benson political editor at townhall.com
you know Karen a lot of people say you
know you're given this too much oxygen
but it is the oxygen that the president
is providing that is driving a lot of
the coverage is it not absolutely I
think anybody who has watched any of
Omir Osos interviews include
her disastrous one yesterday with
Savannah Guthrie doesn't walk away from
those interviews thinking oh I've got to
go out and read this book it really is
the president with his tweets with his
engagement who I think is putting a lot
of fuel on this fire yeah what do you
think of all this oh my gosh well when
the White House is out there and their
primary defense is the president calls
many different people dogs that's maybe
not the best situation for the country
it does happen to be true at least on
some level there is a reporter from
Business Insider who went through and
compiled on Twitter a list of people the
president has referred to as dogs which
included many white men like Mitt Romney
and rahm emanuel and david gregory and
eric erickson the list goes on and on
but here we are the president I think
has a compulsion to fight back it's part
of the reason that a lot of his
supporters love him but you have to
question occasionally the wisdom of the
ferocity of the pushback given the
context here where he's very clearly
punching down in a big way against
someone would I think who I think has
limited credibility to put it kindly
Steve yeah I agree with Karen and guy
I'd add a couple of things I think you
said that she's getting a lot of
attention bred that's exactly right
she's getting the attention but I don't
think she's gonna have any impact I
think this will turn out to be pretty
inconsequential in terms of the overall
scheme of things there's just one thing
I'd like to pick up on because a lot of
people in discussing this have made the
point well why did the president hire
this person in the first place it's a
mistake to bring people like this into
government
you shouldn't have people like that with
no government experience I think that is
the wrong lesson to learn I think it's
often very useful to have Outsiders
people without government experience and
so on in brought into government to
shake things up you don't just want a
bunch of bland bureaucrats however they
have to have some level of integrity and
Omarosa clearly doesn't Karen what about
this Peter strike story is the president
continues to tweet about that Peter
struck fired a lot of back and forth
about how that is all played out and how
really he led the
in these investigations the Trump probe
as well but the president saying if I
had a real Attorney General this would
not be going forward yeah this is again
he cannot get over the fact that Jeff
Sessions recused himself from all of
this at the outside of the
administration and he continues to sort
of dig and dig and dig at his own
attorney general of course if he didn't
want Jeff Sessions there there's a way
to get rid of him he's the president and
I think it also goes to you know the
question of why people don't feel loyal
to Donald Trump in many respects you
know loyalty starts at the top and so we
have seen you know people once they are
out of his orbit they turn on him and
this is something you often see in
Washington you know guy the outrage
meter is always at 11:00 here in
Washington I mean it really seems like
every day is another thing that you know
heads explode about whether it they
should or shouldn't we'll leave to the
viewers at home but guy what do you
think of the political impact here
potentially as we head towards midterms
on both of these stories well I tend to
agree with Steve that on Omarosa this is
a passing fascination
she's wall-to-wall on another network
right now talking to anyone who will
listen about all of these allegations
the one that we played at the beginning
of the clip if true would be huge that
the President or the then candidate
Trump had advanced knowledge of
WikiLeaks possession of DNC emails but
there's not a shred of evidence to that
effect thus far and another network in
fact got in some trouble for making that
claim and had to walk it back a number
of months ago if I recall correctly so
Omarosa I think probably a passing phase
in our national discussion the Peter
struck Russia broader issue I think is
here to stay until Muller wraps things
up because of its it's an all
encompassing topic both parties have dug
in their heels on this issue at this
point and the one thing I will say in
the moment brat is that I'm fascinated
by the sort of cultural
martyrdom that has surrounded Peter
struck and he's sort of being portrayed
as a victim President Trump that is very
odd to me given the black and white text
messages the evidence that we've seen
for which he was fired and all that the
IG said about him now a GoFundMe page
you never know what this country is
going to do next